how to build a successful service based
business I got this question from gonzo
love that name
gonzo marino on my youtube channel thank
you guys love you guys wrote in to say
can you do a video on businesses that do
service i own a lawn service business my
fifth year i'd like to hear from someone
of your input on my line of business
this is a great question and I love
entrepreneurs who start off as service
based businesses and so to really answer
this question we have to look at the
life cycle of your company if you are
first starting out a service based
business is a great way to go
because there's almost no cost the thing
that kills entrepreneurs at the start is
cashflow you run out of cash and you
have to go back and get a job
so conserve your cash stop spending
money if you have a service based
business you're trading your time for
money and so you have the time and
you're going to get the money I don't
want you making huge investments into
anything when you're first starting up
build around your customers and grow
from there so if you're starting a
lawncare company try not to go out and
spend a ton of money right you don't
need an office you don't need fancy
vehicles you don't need fancy equipment
and fancy marketing just enough to get
you started to get your your business
off the ground okay if your longer-term
goals to have products that's great but
start with the service because it gets
you close to your customers and it
brings money in the door you got to
start making some cash so now we're
going to start our service based
business you have to figure out what
kind of business you're going to be in
and what's going to make you different
okay so gonzo here is in the lawn
service business what gonzo didn't tell
me was what makes him different there's
a ton of lawn service companies right I
can go walk down my street look at any
of the telephone poles and I'll see tons
of ads for people offering to cut my
grass in the summer and shovel my snow
in the winter tons of these guys what
makes you different what makes you stand
out what do you believe in why should I
buy from you why should I hire you
what's so great about the experience I'm
going to get with your business versus
doing it myself
hiring my next-door neighbor's kid or
hiring a different company but you got
to have that and when you're talking
about your business you got to you got
to put it
in your messages - you got to put it
here you got to tell me why you're
different not phone your shut off
not that you are just a lawncare company
right it's got to be in here now you've
been in business for five years so
there's something something that's right
right you keep doing is there something
you're doing that's right once you get a
customer you've got to service them
right you're in a service based business
you need to provide great service to
your customers you got to care about
them you got to give them something that
they want to tell their friends about
you need to be remarkable again
something that people want to make a
remark about what is that for your
business because people are hiring you
to cut their grass to rake their leaves
to shovel their snow oh that's great but
they have other problems they have other
deeper problems that they need help with
that you could help them solve that your
competition isn't doing dig in there get
to know your customers get to know their
problems their pains and help them solve
it and if it's just you then you're out
talking your customers and you're
providing the best service possible and
you're fast in your response time and
you're going always over and above the
call of duty to provide great service
for them and if you brought on a team
then they have to be able to do the same
thing and they're professional and
courteous and you know can answer
questions for the customers and they
know what they're doing but you have to
have something that's different right
something that gives people a reason to
keep coming back and hiring you and to
keep telling their friends about you one
thing I found so if we're talking about
the lawn care industry when I had my
first place I used to have a I lived
with my parents for a while then I had a
basement apartment in an area and then I
had a townhouse and then I eventually
built my own house from scratch before I
built my house in my basement apartment
and in my townhouse and in the condo
before that I never had to worry about
blew my lawn it was always taken care of
then I had my house and I had a lawn I
had to worry about this thing and a lot
of people don't know enough about lawns
and I was worried how do I fertilize and
how short-throw cut the grass and how
much need the water and in doing you see
door you saw all of that stuff and ended
up hiring a company
that had a clear simple to follow
maintenance program and they came into
the defeating and the cutting and
everything I needed done and they
explained it to me in simple English
language and they made it convenient for
me and so I hired that company and I
told my neighbors about this company
made my life easier
why wouldn't I talk about them they were
remarkable so how can you do something
similar to really stand out because most
people in that business are not super
professional they don't have big
ambitions it's a guy in a lawnmower
right that's what you're competing
against so you need to have something to
stand out against a college kid who has
a lawn mower and it cuts lawns for 20
bucks on the side or every weekend right
that's what you got to show a little
more professionalism and more service
for your customers that's all the early
stage lifecycle of your business now it
depends on how far you really want to
grow why you're starting this and what
you hope to accomplish what kind of
impact you want to have on your
community and an education for lawn care
maintenance like why did you start this
business I still have no idea what are
you passionate about that's got a shine
through if you want to make this thing
bigger it's hard to scale a service
based business it's a lot harder than a
product you can do it you can franchise
it you can hire more people but you're
still trading your time for money
so do you want this to be bigger do you
want this to grow franchise you want
this to grow bring it on a bigger team
you want to stop trading your time for
money and start building products and
educational series for people how to
manage their own lawns or how to train
people other landscapers to build their
own business right there's a lot of
opportunities for growth that it's not
always going to rely on you just trading
your time for money by cutting people's
grass but you got to want it you want to
want to build something bigger it's not
necessarily for everybody you have to
decide in your heart if that's the right
thing for your business or not at the
core of all of this for everybody who is
starting up I love the service based
business idea again because there's
limited cash flow going out and there's
lots of cash flow coming in that's a
good way to start a business but it's a
service based business you have to find
ways to service
your customers over-deliver like crazy
on your service and your service
business will grow believe if you guys
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below I'll do more for you and I want
to hear we have to say please leave a
comment underneath you have a question
leave it below I'll make a video
response for you thank you so much and
I'll see you soon